you're from northern Idaho yep you moved
to Northern California yep and now you
go to high school there and you have
come down here today to ask us questions
about what
[Music]
I'm not very perfect apartment this is
the official daiquiri run official
Zachary Rodgers interview we're going to
ask you many questions as you add up
maybe some of them will be the same step
and then hopefully in that process we'll
be able to answer some questions about
what we do how we do it in why we do but
a lot of wardrobe my motion video when
it was organized get surprisingly a lot
of people don't know this pro kit if you
want to make somebody look like they
fell super hard throw into cardboard box
ambiguous cue position yeah then you
throw a camp all you need is cardboard
boxes and a camo net and you just bad
guys bidding Zachary Wilson what are
your thoughts here it shows its that
just like every single space on here
just totally done being small and videos
it is so small and it's the problem
[Music]
it is just either so much so you call
our boom boom stuff yeah you never know
when you need a flame fire edition fit
up here with a nerf gun and I like to
shoot out a wiener going to surgically
plans for places you never know who's
going to come through that door we could
just sit in chairs this is an eco mess
it's a classic classic Nikolas with
classic Nikko fashion he takes out a
table all the cameras and a bunch of
other stuff now granted he shot a video
that got 200,000 views with this
equipment two weeks ago but
it's still here for everyone out there
who wants to go from filmmaker buff or
amateur filmmaker or film student to
making a career making videos on YouTube
we're going to talk about that right now
so we're going to answer once and for
all
what's like being digi filmmakers
Oh world is open I could say enforcer
who you are what you do right now and
why you came down here all right so my
name is Zachary Rodgers I live in Auburn
California which is about 40 miles north
of Sacramento
I go to Bear River High School and I'm
the director of photography for our
advanced TV production class when I was
a kid autism mystified my movies and you
know where you're going and you're
planning on going to film school or are
you still searching I've kind of pulled
it together in the past few weeks of
what exactly like my plans plan for
graduation is yeah and what I've come up
with so far is I'm going to go to LA CC
Los Angeles City College and they have a
film course they're kinda like a poor
man's UCLA and get a certificate of
cinema and TV production so I'll just be
taking moviemaking classes 20 hours 25
hours a week then the time I'm not doing
that I can be working on set try to get
internships or just working on my job
how many videos would you say you've
completed up to this point they were on
10 did you're 15 okay seemed like less
bad than what you're doing yeah exactly
that's how you find out yeah so that's
the first lesson it just pick up Cameron
start shooting yep is that you too can
be a digi maker
[Music]
in all the
intimately
what part of working in the fields you
find most satisfying I think when you
have the opportunity to get feedback
from people that are watching yourself
and they're giving you unbiased feedback
one of my favorite things is after you
put out a video to go through the
comments and see what people will say
yes do they like it do they hate it do
they what to do like yeah what do they
like about it and have that engagement
and that's what actually makes YouTube
really cool because it allows you to do
that immediately so I really searched
through the YouTube comments to see if
anyone had questions that weren't being
answered or just kind of overlooked one
major thing that I saw a lot is how
exactly do you guys make money because
you have you felt that every day you do
upload you know very high quality videos
that on average you know grateful
million of you mark so how do you supply
all of this with all the salaries and
all the you know yes I mean your family
man how do you exactly support all that
was an actual income and saladin totally
it's a good question
the first and I guess most basic answer
is that it's a multiple different income
streams that are all based around the
product of what we make here which is
video the beginning of every video
there's Matt so we we make money first
and foremost through that that in and of
itself is kind of its own science with
YouTube the basic rule is that minutes
watch are your key factor to how much
you get paid but realistically we only
get paid about 80 cents
for every thousand people that watch the
video so the next part of that is the
canonical videos which usually are a
little bit longer something that's a
little bit easier to shoot and generally
we get paid a little bit more from those
than we do from the coridor videos
what part not working in the field you
find most challenges that's a good
question
pace of creating videos it's a challenge
not in the sense that it's always hard
but in that there's always a new thing
to be learned and understanding that
each time you go through the creative
process there's going to be something
that you're going to need to learn and
accepting that and then like building it
into how you get to the end goal hmm is
really important and it's challenging
but it's a good kind of challenge you
know it's a healthy kind of challenge so
that can be like a symbol of like trying
to figure out a camera movement in one
shot sure yeah yeah or figuring out how
to edit with footage that you don't have
enough to tell the original sputtering
ship and having to go through the
process of changing the edit to inhale a
different story than you originally
sought out - yeah and then as learnings
back and then how you apply it to what
you do in the future I mean it comes in
many different formats but it's always
there and in an art in an artistic
career like that will always be a true
attention to detail whatever you're good
at you understand the technical side of
how it works and that's part of what
makes you good at it
okay how was your routine dedication and
consistency how you work with other
people going into more that creative
partner sort of thing like once you
understand the technical side and you're
dedicated and you have a routine then
the next thing really is to look for
creative parties that you can
you can work with even though there may
not be the people in your area or in
your Kurt like everyday situation
eventually if you continue to reach out
don't be shy about if you will find
people that that that work well with you
you never want to live in a creative
factory if that was important to have
your own creative identity dip and to
understand creatives like what you want
and looking to your creative voice
follow that but it's always great to
have people that you can bounce ideas
off of people that you can creatively
collaborate with and people that bring
other skill sets to the table that you
might not necessarily have when you're
younger and you want to make art it's
all about demands
yeah right that's where the core of a
lot of creative inspiration comes the
way that all arts is supported is by
commercial yeah so it's very it's a it's
a really interesting thing about lectin
society I mean in back in like the Greek
and Roman days artists would be
commissioned by you know the Emperor's
or the gangs or the government to create
art but in the United States at least we
don't have a system for that
so all art is supported by commercial
enterprise it's a little bit of a catch
point - yeah a sense that you want to
create something that's unique and you
want to own it and you want it to be
original but at the same time it has to
be relatable and has to be sellable and
you always want to find out where that
is and it's it's totally okay to
sometimes to be like you know what I
just want to make this and get it out
there it's a creative thing that I have
inside of me I don't care if anyone
likes it yeah and you just want to make
it and get it out there that's totally
awesome and flying film tool versus just
kind of going out and what
you haven't dude some people choose to
go to film school some people choose to
go out and just go at it and try to
create things and put them out there
there's there's no wrong answer I think
there's a different task for everybody
it sounds like you are kind of taking an
approach to like a blended approach to
it which i think is personally I think
that's pretty smart just going well if
we do what we feel is fun and
interesting
then it'll by virtue of that be original
and hopefully some you know it'll have a
niche yeah no one else has and that's
what we set out to do and I think anyone
that's making anything should always
approach it that way you know you have
your influences but at the end of the
day you have what you make in as long as
you just try to stay true to that it
comes through pretty good sweet man well
thank you for coming down I think you
should really appreciate your time and I
appreciate you coming down here and
representing everyone out there is
listening to start a career as an artist
I'm going to get a lot of email the idea
that television is an expendable form I
believe needs to be eradicated because
the anatomy of the televisual medium is
endowed with methods of storytelling
unobtainable in film for example the
Clarice benefit of a serialized story is
length
[Music]